good afternoon how I right right well
you know I'm up for Best Performance by
an actor it's a performance you know
Reuben is 5 foot 8 160 pounds I'm 61 and
200 pounds so i guess i shouldn't play
the part because i'm not the hacker had
acted for it good afternoon how are you
good
no I didn't know about the the New York
Times and you feel good and I have been
in this situation before both sides of
it so you know I can't tell you that
until it happens I'm sorry no no speech
what'd you say well you know yeah I've
been there before yes
you know what was special last night the
Screen Actors Guild Awards I presented
this lifetime achievement award is
Sidney Poitier that was special that was
an amazing evening I was a great evening
for me and what we talked about
afterwards encouragement that he gave me
that was special to me very special to
me oh oh we talked about the laker game
and how they beat Sacramento and how
close it was yes well first of all I
don't call a competition it's not a
competition you know it's just people
vote people do the best they can
everything that we can do we've done as
actors and then other people do a lot of
things as business people and you know
selling of films and all of that but you
know I think there's a lot of tremendous
work up there and I think everybody
should be proud to even be here today
last one I'm just running things down
haha okay am I rooting for anyone else
in the other category yes